[Music]
welcome to here biscuits I'm Rhett and
I'm link this week at the round table of
dim lighting we have George Watsky AHA
award-winning slam poet and rapper yeah
he's been climbing the charts both with
the release of his new album all you can
do and his ever-growing YouTube channel
watsky exclamation point yes George's
first claim to fame was being featured
on Russell Simmons presents Def Poetry
on HBO this was back when he was 19 in
2006 and more recently you might have
seen him featured and in one or two epic
Rap Battles of History a Shakespeare or
Edgar Allen Poe
Watts Keys breakout viral video I
remember seeing it at the time
blew my mind it was titled then pale kid
raps fast
he was speed rapping over an
instrumental from Busta Rhymes song
breaky and neck he posted that in
January of 2011 and it currently has
over 25 million views so he's pretty
amazing that's a little fast it's just
it's a little faster than I've ever
spoken or thought the words are
subtitled on the screen and I still
can't keep up it's it's mesmerizing you
know so one of the things we talk about
is as an artist kind of dealing with the
fact that being pigeon-holed is that
because it went so viral right it was it
was good to kind of pick his brain about
some piece of viral marketing that he
created himself going to well and then
having to kind of spend the next year
getting out from under that and he's
done that by continuing to make ways in
the hip-hop industry releasing albums
like his most recent all you can do
released August 12th 2014 is already
topped the hip hop and rap charts the
first video release was whoa whoa whoa
posted in June it's got over 2.5 million
views and features comedian Bo Burnham
gonna be today we're gonna beat it of a
pennant in a briquette than it tougher
than heated up a PETA would never
approve by the way I've been treating
the music Abba we did a bruise it I took
it to the kerbin then I'm seven if I
were gonna be freaking and you win
extreme in a movement I'm picking apart
the muscle but I think about the hustle
guys
[Music]
so this one's got some cool effects that
we talked to watsky about we also figure
out what the song says about him I I
expected him to be a very honest and
introspective person because that comes
through and so many of his lyrics we hit
on a bunch of topics authenticity a
number of things you can catch the air
biscuit now but I wanted to say you can
catch Watsky on tour this fall starting
in Europe and then making his way back
to the states he may even be stopping in
India yes well you told us I think he's
trying to work that Australia oh he's
going all over the place to promote this
thing so you should you should go check
it out
so we talked to watsky about his ongoing
battle with epilepsy his controversial
35 foot stage dive in London that left
two fans and himself injured and we get
into the mechanics of rapping as fast as
he does yeah so stick around for that as
well here it is a great conversation
very introspective very honest your
biscuit with watski your CD is 3d yeah
thanks for gifting us a couple thank you
for taking them and we'll make you sign
these when you sign a table as I've
already told you yeah yeah were you like
I'm gonna make a CD but it has to be 3d
how did that happen well you can already
see that the little corner is popping up
on it so so for those of you who are
listening which is everybody and can't
see the CDs that are being held right
now there's a die cut on the front my
name is like cut out on the deluxe
packaging but the problem is it's not
glued down so the little corners at the
end of the W will pop up and make it
real well that's that makes it real it's
a nice feature yeah I guess I mean if we
had you know everything at our
fingertips we'd glue it down but you
know budgets tight these days penny well
if we I glue at our fingertips we glue
it down yeah but that's the first thing
that people get stuck together
that's the first thing that people can
do yeah you know just take a little
dollop of Elmer's or I like superglue
cuz yeah it's fast it's a participatory
album you have to actually finish the
packaging yourself you fix it right when
you get it I mean you do have to give
people a sense of I'm
I got this physical thing because I mean
in this age you have to really justify
people getting the physical thing
absolutely I mean CDs are already
obsolete so if people buy it at the
merch table it has to feel like a
special piece of art and in both of the
albums that put out recently the
packaging was actually an extension of
the record and cardboard castles more so
in terms of the that was the album I put
out last March and that package actually
was a three fold that if you folded it
out and then you could insert one of the
corners into itself and then if you turn
it sideways 90 degrees it's actually a
castle with like little turrets on the
side and then it had instructions in the
booklet for how to build a catapult so
you can buy two copies of the cardboard
castles and then play knocking each
other down with your friends and you get
the synthesis there were a lot of people
who followed through with that
absolutely not no no I didn't hear from
anyone who did it to me it's like the
idea that everything that you do around
a project is an extension of that
project and you should take it all
seriously including the booklet
including the artwork it's fun for me to
figure out how cool we can make the
packaging and and it's not expensive to
like die cuts and color printing isn't
any more expensive it just it takes a
little creativity but it's it's black
and white and then when you can see
through to the inside it's like the
psychedelic colors just like the recent
music video which track is that that's
not the title track all you can do so
that was kind of yeah I'm ten shot at
that the title track incorporate the
visual theme of the album and the album
in a lot of ways is a tribute to my
parents who are on the front and back
and moved to San Francisco during the
summer love or around that time period
and came up in the hippie era and I love
my parents very much I have a really
strong relationship with them and I feel
very indebted to them for where I'm at
in my life you know they gave me have
all the tools that I needed to be able
to follow my dreams and I loved them and
I wanted to have an album that didn't
feel as self-indulgent as the last one
even though it is self-indulgent the
songs are about myself but they're also
about my folks and the way they raised
me and I wanted to infuse the musical
spirit of the stuff the music that they
taught me to love when I was growing up
which for my mom was Derek and the
Dominos and the Beatles and Motown stuff
and and I wanted that sound to be
present on the record well I want to say
that most people do not have pictures
their parents who can make an album
cover this cool like if you ask me you
got to make an album and you got to put
mom on the back of dad on the front yeah
it would be careful there listening
there would be a different feel it'd
just be a different feel my parents
haven't taken a lot of pictures that
look that badass and iconic these ones I
found them in my house I hadn't seen
them until I was an adult and when I
came home one Christmas or something
there were these pictures that have been
taken out of boxes and they were just
physical prints you know back in the day
people didn't have digital cameras they
would actually have to develop the
photography and they would have maybe
one copy of it and my dad had this
picture of himself holding a black cat
which was named Saruman that was from
1971 and I was like dad that is the
funniest picture of you that I've ever
seen he's got the long hippie hair and
the glasses and and looks like I didn't
even notice Saruman reaping in the
corner yes it's it's so funny and to me
those pictures are great was before my
parents met each other but both of them
were taken in 1971 oh wow and my mom was
in her early 20s at the time my dad was
27 which is how old I am now and I
thought there were such crazy
compliments to each other I mean there
are look like they're thinking about the
same thing not only is is your dad on
the right third your mom's on the left
third your dad is right his left side of
his face is lit your mom's right side of
her face is lit they have this like
sadness in their eyes but this like
self-awareness it's it's great
I'm een I think that's the reason to buy
this one you can't turn it into a castle
yeah but you can look deep into my
parents eyes and sense that they're
their inner humanity and you can look at
both at the same time if you do that
yeah it took me five minutes to realize
simultaneous invite has opened up to if
I want to destroy the spine of the
record you could make a make out with
each other to doing it it's having man
there Mouse you can flash back there he
pretty grows Linda discovered that I
didn't know the door was locked when I
was unlocked live and I walked into my
parents bedroom and they said they were
hugging No so what did your parents say
when you record no when you walked in
you were five I actually do have that
memory that's that's not just a silly
story that I pulled out of nowhere
that's from the deep traumatic memory
thanks okay they're gonna said wrestling
no that's what my parents what I said
what did they
say when they saw themselves on your
cover did you tell them ahead of time oh
yeah I mean every time I incorporate my
family into my music whether it's a
photo or a song that's about them I
always ask permission and they were
flattering him I think they're really
honored by it it's not like I wrote an
album that included them and then you
know I'm not like you know I'm not
trying to show them in like tell people
that my parents traumatize me I want to
tell them that I love them and they
raised me well and that I'm proud to be
part of this family and so I think they
were touched by it but they were silent
so there was like an awkward silence no
they actually told me they were touched
okay that's good that's good so the
video for never let it die I'm working
in this circus in search of
learning from the Fergie's perched on
top of the church and children a sermon
you want that early worm be the
determined sparrow flying in loops
around the sternness scarecrow great
song by the way thank you
you got a falcon in this one yeah is it
a hawk or a falcon I'm trying to
remember I believe I think it was a hawk
I think it was I think was a hawk but he
never he never left he never left the
perch and then came back to you you just
perched him there were times when he
would get freaked out or she I don't
remember the species or the gender I
really it's it's actually kind of
embarrassing how little I got to know
this bird didn't ask it or Z about its
story but yeah there were times when the
bird got real freaked out and like fly
off my arm and it was actually tethered
to a little rope yeah there's only so
far that it could fly and then and then
my hand would start moving in that
direction but it was kind of scary I
mean the bird could peck your eyes out
or you really didn't want to freak it
out cuz it would flap its wings up and
we've done a few shoots that have
incorporated animals I did it I had a
goat in one of them and we're trying to
get a zebra for the next shoot but it's
actually hard they there's a lot of
rules about what you can do with an
animal on set which is which is good I
think because you don't want to be able
to do anything I almost it's a living
being and so right we actually had a
falcon on our live show yeah way back in
the day it was we just a guy in our
hometown we were in Lillington North
Carolina and a friend of her friend said
this so-and-so has got a falcon we're
like ooh bring him to our web show and
then we were all we also did a cooking
segment and where we made our own
guacamole so we started feeding
guacamole to the hawk called the hawk
like it or this the Falcon well all the
comments started saying you know
guacamole will kill a hog really and
knowing none of us in the room knew it
right I'm Mikado's will kill a bird
that's so specific and weird he ended up
being okay and we didn't give him
anywhere near a lethal or a damaging
dose but I mean recently we did a llama
shoot and we had to go by the book and
get a monitor like a llama monitor to
from here please
yeah yeah that's that's tragic that the
bird will never know the joys of avocado
my favorite food of all time really
oh yeah of akkad oh yeah so so he got to
taste the forbidden fruit yeah he did
but I seem to be okay I'm gonna tell a
little story that maybe will get me in
trouble but I had a little bit part one
time on Arrested Development the new
season of it and there was a segment on
it where they had a little dove that was
supposed to like there was a magician
Crick because Joe does magic on the show
and that bird was supposed to look like
it's dead like he's doing magic but he
botched the trick so he opens up like
the metal tray and the bird is lying
there on its back dead but the it's
actually harder to get a dead bird for
some reason than it is to get a live one
and so they had to get a live bird that
looked like it was dead so the trainer
took the bird in its hand and then went
oh yeah and then like rattled it around
so it's like brain was gonna and its
skull and then the bird like lies flat
on its back realize it's like brain
trauma and I was like that looks really
good is ask the animal trainer I was
like aren't you giving it a concussion
right now to make it lie on his back
he's like no no it'll be all good yeah I
do this all the time an shut up good and
they got this scene they got the scene
and then did he fly away
I don't think he fly oh I think she's
probably shoved into his little cage or
something but so was there a monitor
they are like no no no no there's no one
he wasn't he was the monitor he was the
trainer the trainer but usually a
trainer and then a monitor who just
stands there and you pay him just to
stand there and shake their head no
maybe we start shaking a bird he might
have been taking bribes under the table
or something I don't know now we have
been enjoying the rapid release of many
music videos the whoa-whoa-whoa
video we've got some questions about
that go for it this technique that you
have implemented you have to explain or
is this a trade secret how is this
visually done it's not a trade secret
we actually explained it the other night
at a we did this screening called flux
where they do a bunch of music videos
and we did a little presentation on how
the effect was done and well just to
explain visually you're rapping but it's
like the video keeps looping back on
itself yeah it's like a Jif or gif
effect there's a stutter effect like it
keeps it shows you a few seconds back a
few times in a few times in a few times
but you're wrapping keeps going forward
yeah exactly so still the way we did it
is we had two shots that we did the shot
where I perform the action so say I'm
dousing this car in gasoline and you see
my hand go up and then the gasoline fly
out of the end of the nozzle so I
perform that action and then we go back
and we find the frame and the director
of photography island was dow ski who's
the one who came up with this concept
lines up the frame exactly where it's
gonna be when I hit that moment of
having the gasoline up in the air and
it's gonna be repeated over and over
again he finds that frame on the monitor
so he's on the side well we're still on
set and we're monitoring it live and
then he positions me back again with
camera and he doesn't opacity thing
where he can see my face and he can also
see the flame that were using before so
he makes sure that my face is lined up
exactly where the other one was and then
he comes in with a helmet contraption
where he beats the opacity thing we can
relate to that because when we did our
t-shirt war stop-motion animation we had
to keep lining up for every shot sure
it's exactly we changed t-shirts so yeah
we did a version of that
yeah well this we're doing the poor
man's version too I mean we started out
very DIY and guerrilla and have been
gradually getting a little bit more
professional as the years have gone by
but he would line it back up
we'd line it back up and he would find
and he'd have to do little adjustments
to my face yeah and then he would come
in with this helmet and he would lock me
into place and for 15 minutes I would
have to stay exactly still because the
whole effect was pulled off by stealing
the maomao from that frame and then
superimposing opposing it on that one
exactly as he worked the edit but the
key to making the effect sell was that
the lighting remains exactly the same on
that part of my face right so that he
can do a little like like fade effect
around the edges of it so that you don't
see that the edges of it that was the
part that I didn't have figured out was
knowing while you're shooting yeah which
frames how he wanted to loop it back how
could you film his mouth in so many
different angles it was very composed
every frame figured out the Edit ahead
of time exactly we was very like shot
listed and we knew we wanted this side
shot and we wanted this one dead-on it
was it was very in the director Jackson
Adams really really
reported it really well before and for
every line we knew what angle we wanted
your music videos have this creative
component to all of them there's always
something to talk about ok this looks
like a continuous shot that's moving
through framed pieces of art that
actually come to life and you're the
character in each one or this is a
continuously rotating 360 degree camera
shot inside of a cab over time add on I
guess I'm I'm curious are is this a
mandate from you to directors that
you're working with or are these your
concepts that you're infusing into the
music video it's completely
collaborative have a very close knit
circle of filmmakers that I work with in
LA most of whom I met in college and
when we were going about planning the
videos for this new al but we sat
together and we listened to the album
which was somewhat awkward for me and we
said okay what are the songs that we
think could best be translated into
music videos so the crike
that's the criteria it's not these are
my singles you know every song in the
album is one that I believe in I I made
like 30 songs maybe in and they're all
songs that I love I cut the ones that I
didn't like and I don't have singles I
wouldn't put it on the album if I didn't
truly love it I really feel like in this
day and age having somebody's attention
is so much of a commodity you have to
make sure that every moment of what you
do is engaging and entertaining and fun
and like thought is put into it and care
and love and so that's true from the
tracklisting top to bottom it's why I
put effort into the packaging of the
album and it and it goes for the music
videos too and so it's such a main part
of marketing is having a music video
that people want to talk about and and
it's so easy to fall off the map and
lose people's attention and I think that
if you don't put out material that's
consistently you know at least even if
people have their favorites and they
don't like one as much as the next they
can still tell that care and effort was
put into all of them and and that's what
I'm going for
for whoa whoa well again another great
song tell us about the music video
concept for that one is it ironic or is
it an extension of what you what the
song means anyway is the song itself
ironic or does the video make it ironic
this kind of ties back into just like
what I'm going for is an artist in
general and I think it confuses some
people because
when folks ask who my influences are one
of the people that I throw out generally
people haven't heard of unless they're
really big fans of spoken word poetry is
a guy named beau SIA and he was on this
old TV show called Def Poetry Jam which
I used to idolize and was on the final
season of which was my first stepping
stone into being an artist and I saw him
perform for the first time when I was 15
years old and I stole elements of his
stage persona because I was so enamored
by it and one of the things that he
would do is he would come out with this
insane hubris and he would just he would
had a poem called on Xtreme and it
sounds very simple but he would talk
about all of the different ways in which
he was so extreme he would go extreme on
a toaster he would go extreme like in
ways that were so stupid about like how
he would make his eggs and stuff but he
did it with his gravitas and his
badassness that made it totally absurd
and that was it he would get people to
laugh just by raising his eyebrows
because of this deadpan stare that he'd
give people and and what I loved about
that is he was being really honest and
he's being really self-deprecating he's
being really badass at the same time and
I've kind of used that same technique
and what I like about it is that it
allows you to pick apart your own flaws
and foibles and be honest about who you
are but at the same time like go out on
stage and be a badass and I love that
you know like I I like putting full
confidence into my performances but also
being honest and so whoa whoa some
people might hear this braggadocio song
and being like this dude is totally full
of himself but to me it's supposed to be
taken ironically and the video the two
setups are one that I'm lighting this
green Lamborghini on fire like a total
badass and then I'm down I'm trying to
light it on fire and then I let myself
on fire because I am NOT in fact a
badass car arsonist well I love the fact
that the visual drives that point home I
mean I think without the visual I still
was like it's ironic and his comedic
like the the irony in in the and the
things that you're saying in the song
they're so clever that an ironic that
they become comical and then I think
it's interesting that in the video you
chose to use comedy actors you know Jim
Belushi and Burnham it's supposed to be
funny and then in the second set up is
the bedroom scene where it's like a sex
scene and for the first time in any of
my 90 music videos that I've shot he
actually used a crew to attest sex to
try and send the clicks up so I
apologize
fans who saw that is shameless and you
know it'll be another 90 videos again
before I use a thumbnail of an
half-naked woman every 90 videos yeah
yeah I get one are you you're in the
thumbnail a little bit you're like
taking her ass there that's how I got
away with it right to his sexual ization
of myself too if she wasn't in the video
I would have been upset for a couple of
reasons
what are the reason well one I would
have felt manipulated into she would
have been in a video yeah okay exactly
she's very beautiful she actually went
to college with me and what was that
phone call like you know actually it was
the the sex scene itself and it wasn't a
true sex scene it was a for play scene
because then I knock a candle off the
shelf and the room lights on fire so
that's also an extension of the
Lamborghini thing right even if I have a
gertrudis sex scene it still ends
abruptly but we were in a row get at the
point yeah so it was a little awkward
because she had like pasties on it seize
this moment where she has to unclasp the
front class bra and I'm like trying to
not look at the breasts that I'm like
I'm not not looking at you gotta have an
eyeline though yeah exactly you have to
have an eyeline and I'm like what to our
lives exactly mono was a little but it
was you know you said you said I got to
have an eye light you had a conversation
with her I did I talked to her about
that yeah and she was like oh go for it
it's fine she knew what she was getting
into was she an actress she is an
actress
and she and she knew exactly it was very
very explicit not the sex but the like
breakdown in the casting that said
there's going to be a moment where there
is implied nudity and there's gonna be a
front class brother you're gonna have to
open up and wear pasties on set and
they're right you know it was it was
there was no bones about it we weren't
trying to push the envelope or ever do
anything that she didn't want to so we
just tried to be very upfront about it
and it was a bit awkward because I've
never done that before
and and not to mention it sounds like
you had to wear a helmet that kept your
head in the same place while she stroud
you for like an hour
well she was gone by the time the helmet
came on yeah we did the straddling scene
and then and then she left in that
helmet cable to put my helmet on
no that's just what I do in the bedroom
anyway I find that it's a it's very very
erotic to discuss strap yourself in
please and let the woman take hope it's
safer that's the ultimate safe sex
absolutely wear a helmet but that wasn't
your first lovemaking scene because you
made out with an older woman on your web
series oh I did that's true
man you're so familiar with my work
that's amazing I'm very honored by that
yeah that was really funny cuz I have
like kind of a running joke through my
stuff that's actually true that I'm
really attracted to older women and have
somewhat of a cougar fetish and so I'm
making out with this older woman in a
car in the back of my Subaru hatchback
and then it turns out that I've like
bogarted Andy Milonakis his lover and
then he comes banging on the the door of
my car and then kicks me out of the car
and then he has sex with her in the back
of my state brew while I'm like sitting
forlornly on the sidewalk and then you
we do the Titanic shot we're like a hand
sweeps across the steamy window and a
single tear rolls down my cheek and
that's called watch he's making an album
yeah yeah I did this video narrative
series that was really fun well while
ago yeah we should get back to that but
well going back to the whoa whoa whoa I
guess my question was I understand your
inspiration for the lyrics and the
hubris and the humor in that but what
are you saying about yourself I think
what I'm saying about myself and this is
true of pretty much all of my material
is that you own your flaws I mean I I
think that what's really important for
me is if if something is happening that
I'm embarrassed about or humiliated
about or could be perceived as a flaw or
weakness that if I'm trying to be an
honest writer I have to acknowledge that
and it goes back to if you say something
or if something is a potential perceived
weakness of yours and you acknowledge it
before anybody else does it takes away
the power of the people who might be
making fun of you for that thing so I'm
never gonna be a pop rapper and if I am
it's gonna be in some weird
left-of-centre way I'm not cut out to be
a pop star I'm quirky and I'm weird and
I try and own those flaws and quirks and
and that's a theme that permeates this
album and cardboard castles and my first
one watsky and growing up did you learn
that lesson the hard way I mean as kids
were you know well as people we're all
self-conscious too
to a certain degree most of us to a
degree more than we're willing to admit
was that something that you learned at a
young age when you were trying to hide
something embarrassing about yourself
yeah I think it's it's a comedians
impulse it's like we don't get made fun
of for something and it definitely goes
back to adolescence and the chips on
your shoulder that you develop when
you're a kid for instance I had epilepsy
when I was in middle school and I still
do but the first seizure that I had was
in seventh grade and I was at a big
public school in San Francisco and I had
a grand mal seizure on the blacktop
while I was running the mile and Jim and
I got back to school after coming back
from the hospital and kids started
calling me seizure boy there's this one
kid who just really that's original yeah
seriously I mean middle schoolers you
know they're real poets and I was
getting relentlessly teased about it by
a few people and and for me you know
humor and deflection is the way to deal
with it if you look like you're getting
beaten by those things then it can
consume you and and you take away the
power of your bullies by getting there
first and I think that's making fun of
myself is something that was always a
tool that I was able to use to you know
avoid getting teased even worse there's
just you make people laugh so do you
think that that was instrumental in you
kind of seeking to become a performer
I've always been an attention seeker and
when I was younger that manifested
itself as me being extremely obnoxious
kid and being really the smart aleck in
class the class clown somebody who was
desperate for attention and those aren't
necessarily positives about my
personality they're also things about me
that point to you know an ego that I've
probably had since I was young and
feeling like I deserved attention which
I don't believe any more than anyone
deserves attention more than anybody
else but when I was a kid I was always
talking out of turn in class and trying
to make sure I was the center of
attention at all times and it wasn't
until I was in high school when I saw
deaf poetry for the first time that I
was able to figure out okay there are
moments where it's okay to ask for
attention and you can put the spotlight
on yourself and if you're a performer it
gives you this outlet to get that
positive reinforcement from people and I
think that gradually over the next few
years I was able to learn okay I don't
need to be the center of attention
all times there are moments where I can
step on one stage and I can get that ego
fix yeah and then you know be a
reasonable person to listen to other
people instead of constantly having a
talk well let's go with the poetry vein
but first let's pause and make sure we
get the full epilepsy story so I mean
how does that conclude well it's
open-ended I had a seizure that year in
seventh grade and you're not considered
epileptic unless you have more than one
seizure so they were just like we'll
monitor you and see what happens and
then I had another seizure two weeks
later and so I had this second one and
they said okay you have epilepsy we're
gonna put you on medication so for three
years I was on an anti-seizure
medication called depakote and it has a
lot of negative side effects that can
totally change your personality and how
sharp you are whether you're able to
dial into conversations and I was able
to actually so I had a normal EEG
sometime in the middle of high school
and I weakened myself off the medication
and then I didn't have another seizure
for 14 years until four months ago I was
at the gym I as a Los Angeles resident
now obviously started to develop you
have to be I join the gym yeah and I
started working out and when I was on
the elliptical machine I had my first
seizure since I was in Middle School and
when that happened how long does it last
and then you just is it's like coming
out of a blackout yeah well many people
have auras what where you can kind of
sense that this is coming but there's
nothing you can do about it and it's
just a general uneasy feeling and it
happened that time too but because it
had been so long since I'd had a seizure
I wasn't think I was just thinking that
I'm lightheaded because I'm getting off
the elliptical and then I blacked out
and didn't remember anything and then
woke up in an ambulance and it's I think
the seizure itself only lasts for a few
minutes but you'd have to ask other
people because obviously I was
unconscious for it and then after that
it's just like waking up from the fog
and that's the strangest experience is
when you're coming to it really is in
the first moments of it you're a human
being but you have no idea what's going
on and I couldn't tell you what decade
it was it's like coming out of a coma
and well and they're like what what
decade is it right now and I have no
idea I'm like and in my mind I'm saying
I'm so sorry - the EMT like I'm so sorry
I'm so sorry I know that I can know what
decade it is but I can't tell you right
now and then you start coming
out of this fog gradually gradually okay
what year it is how many fingers am i
holding up like I'm trying to process
this information I'm so sorry I just
kept saying that over and over again I'm
so sorry I don't know I don't know and
it's a very disorienting feeling at what
point did it dawn on you that you had
had another one after all those years
they told me and it was just like oh and
epilepsy is a strange medical condition
because you at you actually sleep
through the most intense part of it and
then you just are told about it
afterwards
oh you survived it's good because the
most dangerous thing about a seizure is
like if you fall or if you're operating
heavy machinery if you're doing
something the seizure itself is not the
dangerous part except that it can really
if you have a lot of them it can mess
with your brainwaves but you know many
people have a lot of seizures and are
able to be very functional people so are
you just being monitored now are you
like I had another one so I I went on
this medication called keppra meaning
you had one four months ago and then you
had another one so yeah I've had had a
fourth one so I had to when I was in
seventh grade and now I had a second one
after that gym one so I tried to wean
myself off the keppra the doctor put me
on it immediately and I said I don't
want this for my quality of life I want
to try and get off the medication before
I go on tour again I'm willing to
forfeit my driver status in order to try
and be medication free I will say off
the bat I believe that everybody's brain
is different and everybody's cure and
every what's right for everyone is is
not the same but for me being on an
intense pharmaceutical is really
something that I don't want like I
cherish the ability to be myself and to
always be able to think clearly and I
value that and so I tried to get off the
medication in the next day as soon as I
stopped the medication had another
seizure and I woke up in my apartment
and my chin was cut open and I don't
know what happened I was actually alone
and I just kind of like groggily came to
and looked in the mirror and there's
blood coming down my face and then I had
to call a lift and the lifted driver was
just like what happened I was like I
don't really know just take me to a
hospital so I went in and you know they
I stayed and a friend came and picked me
up and we just decided cuz I was about
to leave on warp to her right before
that and that's a two-month tour that's
really intense that I got back from
about a week ago
and I decided to stay on the medication
because if I had another seizure it
would be catastrophic so our touring
plan
and that just doesn't affect me but it
affects all people like tour with my
band members if I had to cancel dates
you know I've fans we're looking forward
to this and so we made a decision okay
you you I I lost my driver's license
status I'm taking lifts around and stuff
and buses and rollerblading and
combination of it but it's uh it's
definitely affected my life but I
haven't had one since then I'm on a low
dosage of Khepera and lamotrigine right
now and I have another tour coming up to
support this album so I'm just trying to
play it safe I'm not drinking at all I
haven't had a beer in three months I'm
not drinking caffeine just like anything
that I can do to make it so that I don't
have another seizure I'm trying to I'm
trying to do right now until I get done
with a touring phase and then I'm gonna
try and get off the medication again
right
do you experience a struggle with any
side effects at this point there's often
an adjustment period to medication that
affects your brain and I've definitely
feel a lot better than I did when I
started it the first few weeks that I
was having it I would have these weird
moments where like say I'm having this
conversation with you right now I would
just lose the ability to be present in
the conversation I would hear you guys
talking and it's like being mentally
underwater and I would know what you
were saying but I wouldn't be able to
respond and add on if you have you ever
had the feeling where you're waking up
from a dream and you want to move your
arm or you want to get out of bed but
you can't do it or yeah and sleep bro so
so I I have it it's like that it's like
that but you're awake and you're sitting
there and I had it on Mexican restaurant
one time with my friends and it was like
five minutes and I was just sitting
there with the chips and I was like I
want to eat a chip I want to be part of
this conversation and then you come out
of it you're like and you tell everybody
like at the table like guys like I'm
back now I just wanted some of those
chips guys you don't even know how it's
going out like this dis intense struggle
that's going on your brain the like and
and it was very weird but I haven't felt
like that in a while and I didn't feel
like that in Warped Tour and I'm really
glad because a robic exercise seems to
be my my epilepsy trigger that that that
could lead to another one but
fortunately it didn't and so I'm
knocking on wood and yeah I'm good for
now all right so take us back to spoken
word and the start of that so I started
my freshman year I got really interested
in hip hop when I was in middle school
and I was just a kid who'd listen to
whatever was on the radio
when I loved Eminem and Nelly and
Ludacris and I loved rapping but it
wasn't until I was a freshman in high
school that I saw poetry for the first
time performance poetry and it blew my
mind this for those of you were
unfamiliar with slam poetry feel free to
type it into YouTube and spend a night
in it it's polarizing artform some
people really don't like it because it
can be kind of preachy and serious and
ranty but those are the reasons that I
think I connected with it as a high
schooler because I was really emo and I
still love it I think it's a very direct
art form and can be a very honest art
form and can also incorporate humor and
lyricism performance and to be a really
really good spoken word poet you have to
be a really solid performer and a really
solid writer because the work is so
personal you can't be a mediocre writer
and a great performer you can't be a
mediocre performer and a great writer
you have to you have to take both of
those really seriously and so that's why
I really loved it
and was there a specific opportunity
that poetry became the outlet initially
versus oh I want to be a hip-hop artist
initially I did both I never I started
rapping when I was around the same time
it just so happened that the first
breaks that I got were as a poet because
there was a spoken-word scene in San
Francisco for young people where I would
go and do open mics and I would go to
free workshops this organization called
youth speaks was a non-profit literary
arts organization in San Francisco that
I became really involved with and it's
the first one you did publicly I had a
poem called beliefs but it was like
terrible you go back and listen to it
it's just cringe-worthy but but you've
got a Tappin is something that you
believe deeply to make those really work
right as you're saying so a poem about
being half Jewish that I did when I was
15
about the fact that I have all these
Jewish tendencies that my father was
stowed on me because he comes from a
Jewish family but that were not Jewish
religiously at all so I felt like I'm a
cultural Jew but not a religious Jew and
all these like Woody Allen type neuroses
I've been like passed on but I didn't
get any of the actual religions I had a
poem called half Jewish about that and
the one line from it that I still to
this day I'm kind of proud of but has
never made anything else was like I
started doing the the prayer but ah I
don't know
melancholy Chomsky Noam Jeff chaotzu
Vikings Randy Moss and super bowl-like
any of the actual prayer stuff and and I
got a good laugh out of that but that
was that was it so I I did those poetry
slams for like four or five years and I
got a little bit better every year and
then when I was 19 I won the San
Francisco City slam it was my last year
of eligibility and so I went on to the
national competition with the Bay Area
team it's a competition where you're
performing original work and then a
random panel of judges scores your poems
on a scale of one to ten so getting a 30
is getting a perfect score and I did
really well when I was 19 in 2006 and my
bay area team won the national
competition at the Apollo Theater and
there were Scouts for Def Poetry Jam
there did you get a 30 I got a 30 for my
my poem v4 version which was Apollo up
being a virgin until until high school
graduation and the Def Poetry scouts saw
that poem and I got onto the show that
the final season of the show on HBO I
was on it when I was 19 which is I'm
really proud of and I wasn't until that
poem that I think they were able to say
okay we get it like this weird quirky
dorky white kid now we can we can paint
him in this way who's we
we is are the producers of Def Poetry
okay who are selecting who is gonna be
on the show and they'd seen me in the
past right because how much of a
minority on that show were you as the
young white kid the show is pretty
racially diverse but I think that like
they didn't know how to peg me at first
cuz I'm not like a suave sexy guy I was
all elbows as a high school kid and I
was doing these like intense political
poems that that they were like yeah
that's cool like you're scoring well and
stuff but like we don't get it and and
even that show as cool as it was that a
poetry show was on TV they were still
Hollywood producers who were trying to
find types for the show oh that kids
talking about being a virgin and he
looks like do it right so but but it was
an honest poem I mean it was in some
ways typecast me as this kind of nerdy
character but it was a poem it was very
honest to my experience in high school
and so I wasn't embarrassed about it
because it was true so I had this little
appearance on HBO that allowed me to get
these college gigs
have you guys heard of the knack a
circuit it's called National Association
of campus activities and I did this NACA
showcase through youth speaks they were
trying to do a college tour so there are
people who are specifically College
booking agents they were like you're
gonna do great in the college market
and that means that you perform at these
NACA conferences and then try and get
bounced around college courses and so I
did that for about four years and for
the first two years I would take all my
classes at Emerson in Boston where I
went Monday Wednesday I would take
really really long class days as a
full-time student but then I would have
Thursday Friday Saturday Sunday at a
four-day weekend so I'd leave Thursday
morning and then I'd come back Sunday
night I'd play like three college shows
in like Iowa or North Dakota or
something and then I'd fly back and I
and I go back to my classes and what are
these crowds like we've talked to some
people before who've done now that you
mention it I do understand yes had some
great stories yeah yeah yeah nice Peter
yeah yeah we've actually connected I
think he may have actually been on the
same college booking agency as me he he
was like in a McDonald's at one point
well yeah it's the story that he tells
and is that you kinda are given this
crowd that isn't out there because they
know who you are and you have to
convince them that you're worth
listening to no there are there kids
that are in like Sioux City Iowa and
they're so bored out of their skulls
that they're just like okay we'll watch
whatever the Campus Activities Board
brought in Friday night and they'll
watch it very passively so you really
really have to work the metaphor that
sometimes I use as a baseball fan to
describe it is as a performer you're
performing for these potentially
extremely in different audiences and I
should say that sometimes I got great
crowds and the campus activity
committees were really passionate about
pushing the show and people showed up
who wanted to be there or poetry kids
but I would say the vast majority of
them were performing for a small group
of kids in a cafeteria or a basement or
a little cafe or something on campus and
maybe 20 40 kids that are sitting
cross-armed like entertain me go and it
can be very demoralizing when the shows
go badly and I did that probably 200
gigs and you drive in your rental car to
your cafeteria and you perform your show
alone and you go back to your motel 6
and and then you eat your your
Stouffer's mac and cheese you bought at
Walmart and watch the daily show and
then call your mom and tell her that you
don't think you can do it anymore you
just can't take the abuse and you've
done it for four years and you're making
the same amount of money that you were
when you started and you were in college
and what was the hope
at that time because what is the
realization of success as a slam poet
well it there is nowhere to go really
and and I think that this is the advice
that I would give to anyone who wants to
be an artist which is there's no such
thing as a realization of success
there's only enjoying doing it and
obviously there's milestones that you
can hit you can set goals for yourself
and try to achieve them but it's also
possible to set goals for yourself
achieve them and still not be happy and
the vast majority of people are like
that because a lot of the people that
get successful as artists got that way
because they're extremely driven people
with a plan for themselves and they
cannot turn an off switch so you're
constantly moving forward and having
trouble taking stock of the small
moments of happiness along the way and
when you're performing alone you have no
one to talk to when it goes badly and
that's when it's really hard but when
it's going great
is is very satisfying so I'll say that
that even though I'm saying that lesson
I oftentimes don't take my own advice
and get really bummed out and depressed
and sad about it and thinking like I'm
not where I want to be but I was working
towards trying to have people take my
music seriously the whole time so even
as I was doing the spoken-word stuff I
was still releasing independent music
and I used that money that I made
touring colleges after school to fund my
first few music videos and around the
time that I graduated I'd gone home for
Christmas break and I came out to LA I
studied acting in college and I was
auditioning for commercials and I wasn't
getting anything and I was really
depressed and I felt like I wasn't gonna
make it in LA and I went home and I
remember just lying on my bedroom floor
feeling sorry for myself looking up at
the ceiling feeling like man what am i
doing I should have gone into a career
that helped other people instead of
being a failed egomaniac and so I kind
of tried to say okay you have this skill
set that's kind of strange if you were
to boil down what you're good at and put
it into a 90 second video what would
that 90 seconds of entertainment look
like and so I set out to create a video
that was like a commercial for myself
that people would want to share and I
said okay I've got this skill at rapping
pretty fast but it has to incorporate my
sense of humor it has to have wordplay
in it it has to be entertaining and it
has to be a live performance thing so
people can see I'm in fact doing it at a
time so I did this fast right video over
the Busta Rhymes break your neck which
is like music that I started listening
to
when I was a freshman high schools that
era of music something else that I
really loved and it was a success I mean
and it seems like you had more you had
more than the obvious skill that was on
display in the video you had the idea to
call it pale kid raps fast which is
exactly the kind of things that
shameless clickbait but it works it
worked and it did work and it worked
almost too well I mean it was it was
instant success it was just an overnight
boom and it was like within 20 minutes
this thing had been shared like ten
thousand times and the next morning it
had like four million hits on it and we
were getting calls from The Ellen Show
and stuff how long did you sit on it
before you upload it it was it like I
have this idea twelve hours later it was
up on the internet or was it a couple of
weeks or I don't mean waited a week or
something in fact before that video went
out I'd shot a music video called an MC
name for one of the songs off my first
album and the idea was okay we're gonna
shoot this viral video but we need to
have an instant follow-up to it that
showcases what I my real songs so that
I'm not a flash in the pan if this
succeeds and it succeeded beyond my
wildest dreams tell us more than details
about what happened because it it was
crazy well I remember we went out and
got drinks that night cuz we were like
Jesus Christ like we made something of
people watch like it was so it was
exciting for us and I've been putting
out spoken word poems and traveling the
country and playing for like 20 30
people and having no one there and being
demoralized night after night and not
that there were as all demoralizing you
know I was making money as an artist
yeah I have to be grateful and pinch
myself even to perform for that many
people and get it checked to come to a
college but but I was feeling like I was
totally at a dead-end and so then this
video came and we're like oh my god like
we might be able to parlay this into
something else and so then the the
battle became okay we have people's
attention right now how can I translate
this into the career I want to have and
I think that there was an opportunity
for me to maybe go in a different
direction and and do pail kid raps
faster and PillCam raps even faster than
that and going back to the animal
conversation we had actually I had this
idea cuz I was thinking that was what I
had to do I got to incorporate crazier
animals into it and I was like okay pail
kid raps fastest with the slowest loris
I got the fastest rapper in the slowest
one and then I looked into renting a
slow loris and I realized that these
slow lorises men are actually poisonous
and also it's very bad for them to be
exposed to light the reason they're so
cute and they lie on the back is because
they're nocturnal and being traumatized
by the light so we scrapped the idea we
realised how inhumane it was but but we
have walked across the intersection at
the speed of a slow loris oh that was
very experimental recent that's how I
know that they're toxic I also wouldn't
recommend that yeah no it's all bad just
stay away from lorises in general but
you get a call from Ellen yeah is that
an automatic yes no it was a think for a
second and then yeah okay of course but
at first I mean immediately within a day
of having this video come out I was
worried about getting pigeon holed in
this way and it is something that I've
had to battle for a few years is like
the stigma of being a gimmicky fast
rapper and and I'm not ashamed I still
if I had to do it all again I would
absolutely do that video again because
it's giving me so many amazing
opportunities and so many genuine fans
one of the things that you that I see
that you have done is that video is no
longer called pail kid raps fest it's
called Watsky raps unlisted people still
find it and we we were actually looking
just a second ago was up to like 25
million views in like every few hours
somebody's like I found it yeah because
and and I think that it kind of ties in
with something else we were talking
about respect is so important as an
artist in general but I feel like in
hip-hop respect is more important yeah
and so it seems like you immediately
started seeing that like this could be
too good in the wrong way right and I've
got to counteract that it's my
perception of it is that you've more
than counteracted it but you're saying
that this is something that you struggle
with since the initial success it took a
year after that video came out for me to
actually get bookings at real venues at
real clubs as an artist and I had a
first cold call places I couldn't get a
booking agent who would book me in clubs
and I had to do it myself I was trying
to convince people like I love YouTube
I'm gonna continue to exist and be a
part of the YouTube community but
there's more that I want to do I want to
be a live performer and I want people to
take my work somewhat seriously and so I
started just emailing the venue's I
would look through
dates of the artists whose careers I
admired and who were at where I was sort
of in terms of the size of their
audience and I looked through the
listings of the venue's they were
playing in different cities and I was
like okay the drunken unicorn in Atlanta
and I would email their Booker and I
would email the person in Minneapolis
who did triple triple rock or whatever
venue was the size that I thought I
could play and I would say here's my
elevator pitch for why you should book
me and the vast majority of them ignored
my emails there may be four cities in
the country that we're like okay we'll
book a show with you
and so I booked the shows independently
and then at that same time I found a
booking agent who because I established
these cornerstone gigs were like okay
we'll route the rest of the tour around
them for you and we'll see what happens
we'll roll the dice and that's when we
went out in 2012 on the nothing like the
first times were and it's taken a long
time and were you were you with anybody
at that point or was it just you solo
show actually went out with a guy named
dumbfounded who's also had like YouTube
following first it was a battle
wraparound grind time and he came out
and did the tour with us but you know
it's still taken a while and last night
I played a gig called low-end theory in
LA which is a really small venue that is
kind of like the hipster tastemaker gig
where like flying Lotus and all the
people who are like hip beat makers go
and I bombed last night and it was the
first time since the college gigs where
it was demoralizing it's like holy Sh
like like half the audience left during
my show and it wasn't because I was
performing badly because I played on
Warped Tour all summer for 50 shows and
the audience was going nuts and I had
like thousands of people at some of the
shows and it just goes to show that you
can't appeal to everybody as much as I'm
gonna change some people's minds there's
always gonna be pockets in communities
who don't what you do because music is
so subjective and you bring your story
into it and if someone decides not to
like you you know it could be as much
about their perception of who you are is
what you're actually doing and and
hip-hop especially it's important what
you do but also the perception of
authenticity is really important for
some people the way the music that I
present they perceive it as very
authentic but for some hip-hop heads
they perceive it as very much not
hip-hop what they come to the genre to
expect for me when I listen to eggie
azalea I hear her music and I think
she's putting on a voice like you hear
her in interviews and I apologize to
eggie Azalea fans out there but but
there's certain artists that I listened
to him like man you
you don't sound in your music like you
sound like when you're having a
conversation with me and that's the
opposite of what I'm going for when I
want people to listen to my records I
want them to say this is the same dude
I'm sitting across from the table from
there's no air being put on he he is
himself on his music and when some
people listen to my music they think oh
man he sounds like a corny white dude he
sounds like a nerd well guess what
that's kind of Who I am so right you
know I'm gonna do that and bring it to
the table and be unashamed about it but
I'm also gonna try and be a good rapper
like it's not a gimmick that I want to
lean on as a crutch it's just to say I'm
gonna be myself and bring it to the
table and take it or leave it and some
people leave it in retrospect having
done the lots Keys making an album
narrative series does your do you think
that at times your comedy works against
you in terms of being as legitimate and
specifically for that project I'm
curious why you decided to do that and
was it effective for what you wanted to
do was it a marketing tool was it a
passion project it was a passion project
and I don't think that it hurt me or
helped me in any way it was just
something fun that I got to do and I
don't think that hurts you because you
look at a lot of rappers they act and
have been in funny projects I think that
it's it's accepted and it's okay for you
to exist across multiple platforms and
have a sense of humor and be
self-deprecating especially if that's
what you do in your music so yeah I
don't think it's helped or hurt me it's
not like it's skyrocketed me to fame or
it got me a bunch of Hollywood parts but
what I want and there's gonna be a time
that comes when my knees give out and
I'm no longer able to tour 90% of the
year and be a rapper when I'm gonna have
to find something else to do and I hope
I have a long career as a writer and
performer and I want to get into
narrative and maybe someday I'll be a
screenwriter and one of the reasons that
I wanted to get out of this constant
college touring because I figured out a
formula that worked and I did the same
show and for like the last two years I
was just on autopilot and I knew how to
do it and I knew what it how to succeed
and do the right pop cultural references
that would make the college kids laugh
wherever and and it felt lazy to me and
I wanted to do something that scared me
again and that's how I felt about
getting into the club touring and before
I was able to actually do it
I had no idea if I could actually put on
a show as a headlining rapper in there
entertain people I didn't know what it
took to make that show successful and I
was deathly nervous I I was vomiting the
first night
where I played my first club gig as a
headliner at a certain point I'll
probably feel that way about music and
I'll want to do something else again and
and that's what I viewed that narrative
project as like flex your muscles try
something that scares you and and have
fun with it
well I do definitely get the impression
that authenticity is very important to
you that you're not a fan of hypocrisy
and in your recent song ink don't bleed
you-you-you start off the first first
talking about some people who are who
are hypocrites some guy hits about the
rack something burning
see there's Benjamin's and Jackson's in
the pockets of burn but when they shoot
the video producers pass around a book
and full of rented jewelry for them to
rock and return then you start talking
about yourself and you address the event
that happened on the Warped Tour in
November 2013 last year I mean for those
of you who haven't seen it I took the
extremely stupid decision to and I
should preface it by saying that that my
stage show at that point I was taking
increasingly big risks on stage and I
would jump off speaker stacks and there
was a moment at a show that I played in
Wisconsin for a Halloween outdoor party
where I jumped off like the roof of a
frat house and a crowd of people who
like crowd surfed me to the front of the
stage and I was starting to feel like
I'm this I can get away with stuff and I
started to feel invincible which clearly
is not the case nobody's invincible
bones break and and they did in this
scenario I was playing a show in London
at the Warped Tour in the one of the
biggest venues I've ever played
Alexandra Palace in London where the
stones have played and and you know I
started to believe my own hype and I
climbed up a 35-foot lighting rig and
jumped off of it and now let's pause for
a second yeah 35 feet very high I'm not
good with visualizing numbers but I saw
the clip a nose oh that's 35 feet it's I
mean it's crazy people watch the video
and they're like that guy's a idiot like
how could I ever be a fan of his work
it's it's really like one of those
things where you can point to a couple
other people who have done something
that stupid but those people had much
bigger fan bases than me and audiences
who really really liked them and wanted
to catch them
and I was performing a Warped Tour which
wasn't my crowd and I don't know why I
believe that this would be successful
and you know I did believe I would get
caught by them as ludicrous as it sounds
when you watch the video I didn't do it
because I was trying to be a human
missile and injure people I did it
because I got up my own and I thought
that I could get away with something
that I clearly couldn't and there's
something in my brain that's so weird
because I'm a very organized person and
I'm a planner in my career like I'm
thinking many steps ahead but the minute
I step on stage that part of me melts
away and I'm trying in every moment to
put on the best most entertaining show I
can for the audience and you know it got
away from me and I made an extremely
irresponsible decision and it yeah it
was like in the heat of the moment but I
thought about it maybe like a song
beforehand and I was thinking like oh
man maybe when the big climax comes I
can climb up that thing and they'll
catch me and it'll be awesome and I'll
be legendary and it'll be this great
thing where I'll be hailed as like the
most brave like awesome performer and
that's what I was thinking and I got up
there and then I looked down and I was
like holy what are you doing like you
might die right now and and and all
these thoughts are happening in the
split second and I could realized it was
way too high for me to climb down and I
could have but I decided to just jump
off it and it was mitigated by some
factors that made it even more dangerous
that he didn't realize at the time like
for instance I was backlit by the lights
that were in back of me so the audience
below couldn't actually even see me
because they were seeing shining lights
coming right in back of me and then I
also threw my hat off because often when
I go crowd surfing I take my hat off so
the audience can snatch it off my head
so so that I'll throw it back to stage I
threw my hat off but I threw it into the
crowd and so people were looking down at
the Hat when I was coming at them and I
hit these people and I broke a girl's
arm and a guy's back was injured and
both of them went to the hospital and
what happened to you I was a dentist I
also went to the hospital I was put in a
neck brace I was in the ambulance with
the girl whose arm was broken and I
didn't know how badly I was hurt
but it was all bangs and bruises and I
cut my lip open with my tooth
but it I had a few stitches on my lip
but it he
up I was not badly hurt and the wind
knocked out of me and was deeply
humiliated and felt horrible for the
people who I injured and I've done my
best to try and make it right with them
and I haven't heard anything from the
girl you know I'm assuming for legal
reasons they're not allowed to get in
touch with me so I haven't been in touch
with her I was in touch with the guy for
a while
I don't want to go into extreme detail
about it because there is some legal
stuff going on but for the people just
so it doesn't seem like I'm trying to
obfuscate anything you know I've done
everything that I could to try and make
sure that they're better and that I've
done everything I can to reach out to
the best of my knowledge they're all
right but I can't say that with absolute
certainty because I don't have him on
the phone saying you know I've healed up
I've tried to do everything I can and
just address the situation and be honest
about it
it was tough like you know at that point
I was thinking oh is it is it
insensitive for me to go on with a
career and just sweep this incident
under the rug and pretend like it didn't
happen and keep releasing albums and
playing shows and stuff when I've
altered the course of several people's
lives but even before you got to
considering those things was there a
moment of fear that I may have just
really damaged my career absolutely it
was it was a combination of that and
fear that I'd really ruined people's
lives and you know they may still have
fallout from this I'm not sure if you're
listening to this all I could say is I
hope that you're 100% back to normal in
your daily life and to the best of my
knowledge you are but I'm not sure and
then you say you wrap up that verse
bandage the wound and vanish blanka's
the newest of canvases when they zoom in
the cameras give up the truth what's the
truth about you that maybe you
discovered in this that I can't hear in
those lyrics I think the truth that I
discovered is that my egos bigger than I
thought it was and that there was a
desire to be a rock star that I was
playing into and that I need to examine
and address and and really try and work
on because that didn't just happen for
no reason it happened as a manifestation
of something that's inside of me which
which i think is is partly my desire to
put on a good show and to be
entertaining and to always give 110% at
every single show that I put on but that
doesn't have to come at the expense and
the health and the safety of your
audience there's a line between
putting on a great energetic show and
damaging equipment and people and that's
something that I really needed to work
on and have tried to I had a PR person
at the time who's a great person but we
didn't completely see eye to eye on how
to handle the situation and they were
suggesting you know maybe wait about
this and and don't address it and wait
for it to blow over and I just the guilt
was eating at me and so the next night
at the hotel or that night at the hotel
and in London I fits just feeling
totally gutted just like I'm gonna just
post up my feelings I'm not gonna let
this fester I'm gonna I'm gonna own this
and then I'm gonna let whatever happens
happen and that was your fate it was a
Facebook post that I made him hours
afterwards and you know I'm not gonna
have a PR person vet it I'm just I'm
gonna write it and you know let people
take it or leave it and a lot of people
you know they did not forgive me at that
time and I got trolled really really
badly and then no we went on with our
tour I had like five more shows six more
shows at what point did you write Inc
don't believe we write this verse kind
of unpacking it it took a while I
finished the tour and I kind of limped
through the last five date shows of it
and I was co-headlining with a rapper
named wack so I did warp to her with ya
and we flipped around normally I was the
closer and wax with the guy who would
open but for the last five shows I
opened and he closed because I just
wanted to get it over with I was having
trouble eating I was very depressed
about it and I didn't want to cancel the
shows because I had fans that maybe were
waiting for months to see it and I felt
like it was a disservice to them and
that not going on with my career was not
the brave move to make either that that
that there had to be a fine line that
the only way that I could do this and
continue to be an artist in somebody
that I felt like was putting it was
creating a good example for my fans in
the midst of a bad example that I set
was by being a good example of how to
deal with a terrible miscalculation and
so that's what I've tried to do and it
took like four months to write that song
and it sounds like there's specific
lessons learned but I hear in the song
that there's also a larger point that
maybe you're making you say I'm a
complicated guy but then used you talk
about megachurch leader sleeping with
male hookers Mayer's hitting crack pipes
with their cookers is it I mean are you
complicated are you a hypocrite I mean
what do you
what are you saying what I'm saying in
that song is that what I bring to the
table as an artist for those people who
continue to want to listen to my music
is that I will always be trying to be
truthful about my experience and so much
of this industry that that we work in is
about artifice and about presenting an
artificial image I and I believe that
Iggy Azalea is presenting a very
artificial image to people she's not the
only one and and there's it's not a
terrible thing you know they figured out
a way to make a lot of money and to
appeal to lots and lots of people but I
think there's something more powerful
about telling a story in a real way and
people can follow me and if I lost a
bunch of fans through that at least the
people who stuck around are gonna know
how I really felt about it
I don't have a major label telling me I
can't do something and that permeates
politics and every every walk of public
life people doing crisis management and
stuff like that all the stories that I
told at the beginning and the first
verse of that song that sets up the
second verse about myself are true
stories that I've heard in the industry
of you know the fact that there's a huge
pop star who will shall remain nameless
right now that I've heard actually not
only doesn't write her own material but
actually has session singers that come
in and record all of her vocal parts has
no part in the making of her album
whatsoever except the fact that she goes
into a studio one day they take her
picture and put it on the cover and use
her name and that's crazy
and people idolized that person and
they're their favorite artists and
people are impressionable and sometimes
it's really hard to distinguish between
what's both what's not and all I can say
is I'm trying my best to not put out
both it's funny even in my first stalker
you're kind of dealing with the same
thing you're talking about your stalker
but you're dealing with her expectations
right
[Music]
and fill it in
it's kind of that same message I'm
trying the best I can to be honest but
actually not being a hypocrite means
saying that I'm a hypocrite right it's
like you had to apologize to your
stalker I in fact stalked that stalkers
Twitter account because I was so curious
to see how they would react to that song
and my hope was that they would view it
as a tribute and as an as a fan they'd
be like wow like there's a song on his
album about me that's amazing and and I
don't say anything disparaging about the
person but then I found out I read the
Twitter account that they were no longer
a fan of mine and they didn't like my
album they didn't like my cardboard
castles album anymore either that that
this album they loved so much
they now decided that they'd grown out
of and didn't like it and so you were
disappointed that I was really
disappointed actually a stalker had lost
interest two stalkers no longer even a
fan of mine anymore but the song itself
is about Kate this person's looking like
waiting for me outside my house waiting
for me to leave wondering what I might
do what's the difference between what
they think I'm doing inside and what I'm
actually doing which is in fact
extremely unglamorous stuff so well that
this recurring theme of authenticity and
a problem with hypocrisy do you think
that that spills over into your you seem
to kind of have a beef with organized
religion that comes through most clearly
in your drunk text message to God spoken
word for those of us who grew up wishing
we believed in an afterlife and for
those of us who were so close to God we
could practically lean over and make out
with her tell us about your relationship
to that I should say those those two
things that I believe in are a little
bit separate in that the specific
religious line in Inked don't bleed is
about Ted Haggard the pastor for the New
Life Church who was an anti-gay Crusader
who was then caught smoking meth with a
male prostitute and that hypocrisy
spills you know John Edwards who's like
this family man who's then exposed as a
cheater with an outside family and and
this thing this this narrative that we
hear over and over and over again this
idea that like we expect our politicians
to disgrace themselves that was what
that line was about that guy and so my
beef
or is with religion that masquerades as
something it's not so churches that are
profiting off their congregation huge
mega churches that are eat reeling in
tons of bucks are propagating this
message you know often at the expense of
other marginalized groups and then
making millions of dollars for their
rich pastors who are driving around in
Mercedes and and that I have a beef with
I'm not a religious person but I don't
have a beef with people who are
passionately religious because I don't
know I can't tell you if there's a God
or not I think there's probably not
based on what I believe objectively that
I've seen of the world but I didn't I
don't know you know like I can't tell
you with absolute certainty there's not
a God but what I can say is I feel like
sometimes I can smell a rat and when I
see some super rich pastor who's leading
a giant congregation that looks like a
rock concert I don't feel like they're
even following the teaches of teachings
of Jesus Christ which are you know about
loving people and supporting those in
need and I think there's tons of very
empathetic religious people who got into
it for all the right reasons
and who for all I know may may hold the
key to getting into heaven and they're
gonna be laughing at me from the pearly
gates I don't know but you know I my
beef is more with with the fake elements
of large organized religion than with
actually religion itself right and how
does that theme of authenticity how does
that fit you into the landscape
landscape of hip-hop in general which is
about a lot of pop in circumstance and
image there's a definitely always
examples of rappers who break that mold
but in some ways I think that maybe it
limits my growth and if I fit a more
poppy image that maybe I would earn a
lot more fans and be able to be on the
radio and if I had a look you know I
don't have that I'm gonna wear what I
feel comfortable in and act how I feel
comfortable and and that might mean that
I am relegated the more niche fandom for
the rest of my career but I guess only
time will tell but I would rather have
the industry and success come to me
where I'm at then try and fit myself to
something that feels very in genuine and
then in a best-case scenario having to
live with a bunch of success that I feel
like I earned falsely or in a worst case
scenario they
killing and then having to deal with
being a faker who is unsuccessful and a
fraud so I feel like at this point I
could close things down by asking can
you teach me how to rap fast I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna ask that question I
don't mind how do you feel about that
question I don't mind and I should say
like the fast rap stuff even though the
fact that I was associated with it I'm
still I still do it at my shows I'm
still proud that I'm able to do that but
that's technique and skill to me but
that's not how you move people and tell
a story but with that being said I'm
proud of being a technician and I can
tell you exactly what I think the
building blocks to being a good fast
rapper are well but before you do that
so let me get it straight it it seems
like you called it the gravy you called
it not an essential part well it isn't
it's an essential part of what you do
that probably varies from person to
person depending on what well for you as
an artist in terms of when you approach
a song are you like I'm going for it
here yeah yeah and that's how I
approached whoa whoa whoa yeah and and
in some ways that was the
attention-getter song that I was trying
to get people to listen to the rest of
the album I've kind of viewed my
material in in subversive ways of you
know I I believe that that there's
nothing wrong with being an entertainer
that's not a dirty word to me for a lot
of poets and a lot of writers they view
entertainment as a cheap form of art or
not even art at all I love entertaining
people and entertain people you have to
acknowledge your audience's expectations
and try and meet them halfway with
something I'm not a therapeutic writer
who says I'm writing only for myself and
I don't acknowledge my audience I think
acknowledging your audience is a
respectful thing because being a writer
is a conversation between you and
another person you need to be able to
communicate to that person and
communicating to them in some ways
requires acknowledging what do I need to
do to get this person to want to listen
to me and so you so you engage speed in
order to entertain an audience but not
because you want to do it no I don't
have any I do like doing it I was a
drummer the reason and that's gonna be
part of how I explained how to do it I
think it's awesome I love rhythm I love
playing with rhythm I love playing with
rhymes it's not the fact that it's fast
that's awesome it's the fact that it's
precise and that the rhyme schemes are
cool and in fact you can rap really
really fast and still sound like ass if
you don't like if you're not precise
with it and your rhyme schemes aren't
interesting right and in fact that you
can still discern what you're saying is
pretty yes it's about it's about being
being like really clear with it which is
diction which is so rhythm and diction
are the two things that I'm gonna
explain in a second but but it's like
saying to a singer like being is being
on pitch important to you like that's
maybe it's it's impossible to separate
technique from the meat and potatoes
well and before you you give link is
lesson which I will I will also listen
to so we can apply it to our next rap
battle
here's a sports analogy for you my
perception of it is that fast rapping to
you is like the fadeaway de Jordan the
fadeaway didn't make Jordan Jordan but
it's like it's kind of the go-to thing
that is kind of like he does that better
than anybody and if I'm gonna have a
poster in my room is gonna be of him
doing that right there's actually fans
who come to the concert for different
things and I try and always vary it so
that everybody who likes different
facets of my work got what they came for
and the majority I'd say more people
definitely the fast rapping stuff hits
them there's a bigger audience for it
but there is still that contingent of
people who say wow he's a rapper but
he's the guy who also does some spoken
word so that might be a minority but
yeah I I'm not ashamed
if you want to call me a fast rapper
that's fine you know if that gets you to
buy my album and be curious about it and
listen to it and piques your interest
you say I was actually pretty good then
I'm willing to I'm willing to do a
little a little dance for you if that
gets you to listen to my stuff okay I'm
gonna keep myself as suspense even more
with a follow-up question here if faced
with the choice which would you choose
if had you had to sing karaoke either
one of your own songs amongst friends
and strangers or an Eminem song which
would you choose
Oh Eminem every time and and if faced
with another choice I would pick a lanús
more set instead of either it's
self-indulgent like I don't I I get my
fix of my attention I'm not the guy
who's gonna show up to the party with a
guitar trying to play my own songs like
that's just douchey so yeah definitely
an Eminem song and and and I even think
that as a rapper going up and doing rap
at karaoke like why would you do that
get up and sing sing build me a
Buttercup or something so tell me how to
do it
yeah I mean it's two things its its
rhythm and in some ways rhyme scheme is
built into rhythm and then clarity so I
would say because I have a background as
a drummer when I'm writing a fast rap
verse before I even do anything I'm
listening to the beat and I'm trying to
figure out what cadence and tempo are
right for it and then beyond that you
have to know that how how your rhythm is
going to be broken up but what the
stress patterns of it are so it's not
just thinking okay there's a rhythm in
drumming called second line which comes
out of New Orleans like jazz music and
it's a syncopated thing syncopated means
you're putting the stress and emphasis
on a note that's off of the downbeat so
you're creating forward momentum by
basically switching up the rhythm and
second line is a syncopated rhythm that
goes suck at the cat the cat the cat the
cat the cat ducka ducka ducka ducka
ducka ducka thick and a lot of the fast
drive stuff is a variation on that
you're creating this really interesting
pattern by by figuring out what you're
stressed syllables are so now you have
your sort of rhythmic structural pattern
and then you have to figure out what
your end rhymes are so a Multi rhyme you
know cat hat bat mat all round with each
other but the multi rhyme is when more
than one syllables rhyme with each other
at the end of a phrase let's see dog
would be like what I look like
log hit it's in the bog pit and frog
quit you know there's obviously what you
want to do with your good if you're
creating a great word group of multi
rhymes it's have ones that are related
to each other so that you can start to
see the subject matter link between
those end runs and then once you have a
bunch of multi rhyme groups that like
stack up on the paper you start to
figure out okay what are the
associations between these phrases how
can I fill in the gap because I have to
get with the like filler note they're
gonna go Digga Digga Digga Digga bog wit
they get to get digga digga digga
tagalog and then you're figuring out in
the
in the filler words what is gonna get
you from point A to point B so that your
verse makes sense and so once you have
your kind of rough outline of your verse
you're then you have to figure out what
are the trouble spots
and a lot of those fast syllable stuff
comes from making sure that you're not
sticking too many cluttering it up with
consonants so if you want that really
like machine-gun rhythm like buddy got
abide together got nobody I got about
the god damn I got about like you want
percussive consonants in there
gah buh duh kheh are more percussive
than mah nuh nuh nuh so if you have a
word that ends with a vowel and the next
word starts with a consonant you don't
want to end your word with a consonant
and then start the next word with
another consonant that means that your
mouth has to change positions to get to
the next thing because then in the space
of a nanosecond you have to get your
mouth from an R sound to a st you know
sh t sound that it's a lot to clutter it
up with you want to go consonant vowel
consonant vowel consonant vowel so you
can get this really like machine-gun
pattern you could have charged a lot of
money there's a lot of inside baseball
to this and I'm gonna say it because I
think you know if you want to go for it
and practice it it just takes a lot of
time so more power to you yeah step one
is understanding which could take
listening to that a number of times and
then so then it's addiction I was very
lucky to be a theatre student and to
figure out you know red leather yellow
leather red leather yellow leather
unique New York unique New York you know
clarity is so important making sure that
if you have trouble spots in your verse
that you're addressing them you get in
the shower you just do your thirty times
in a row and you need to be so confident
be able to nail it every time that your
mom could be like showing naked pictures
of you as a baby to like you're your
biggest crush in the background you're
so focused you could do it a million
times in a row so so that's pretty much
it it's as easy as that that's what I
will close with this so thanks for
humoring us I really really legitimately
don't mind talking about it and I'm I
get to decide what songs I put on my
album you know and you guys are helping
me slang that to the masses so you know
that's what people are gonna see my new
stuff as and and I'm not ashamed when
fans come up to me after a show and ask
me to do the fast route for that might
gladly do it if you like that and you
love it then I'm proud because I'm I'm
proud that song that that video was
successful mm I'm just not gonna let it
define me for the rest of my life yeah
well listen man thanks for spending this
time this is a very enjoyable it was fun
for me to do yeah I really appreciate it
who doesn't like getting to talk about
themselves for long time
[Music]
and there was our ear biscuit with
George Watsky at what point link did you
lose track of his explanation about how
to rap fest yeah at some point in there
I was like okay so what you're saying is
you either got it or you don't
it made sense I always appreciate it
when someone is willing to pull back the
curtain so I'm glad he did that it was
fascinating I it was it did make me
think about our process for writing
songs and especially writing raps I mean
it's I wanted to ask him we didn't quite
get to it but the starting point for us
we've learned more and more needs to be
the jokes right what we'll actually
write out concepts and jokes before we
have any idea of how they rhyme so then
it's just a question of how do we make
it fit I imagine he has reams of
notebook paper where he's creating
stacked rhymes but he obviously starts
with a message - it's not like he's yeah
yeah it's not like he's stacking rhymes
of all these words sound good together
let me find a way to make a meaning but
I think the fact is that you can make if
you have an underlying message you can
make a lot of different words get that
message across you know and I think it's
interesting because you get the idea
that he's a technician in the way that
he goes about this and that's how it
sounds when you listen to it whereas I
think that I don't think anybody would
never be fooled into thinking and
listening to us rap that these guys are
rappers they would say these guys are
comedians roaring and it's funny it's
because it is very much based in the
approach well and there's the skill
let's go level there's a I mean his
there's a lot of comedy and Watts he's
music were funny but I I'm trying to
figure out what the difference is
there's a different type of comedic
timing that we try to employ that our
songs are tooled around lines being
jokes
whereas with him his his lines are
tooled around being more of a technical
constraint and I think that he has funny
concepts
but I don't know if he sets it up like a
punch line like when you have to set up
a set up in a punch line there's a
certain amount of comedic timing literal
timing associated with that that you
can't really invert as well I mean so he
doesn't do jokes he does conceptually
comedic ironic I mean all different
types of ways he's being funny but it's
not it's a different type of constraint
and the ones we have that are more joke
oriented well it's obviously working and
I think that you know like we talked
about there's this idea of continuing to
gain respect and to separate himself
from that perception of it just a guy
who had an internet video that was
titled well and did something and
demonstrated some amazing skill I mean
he is a legitimate artist without
question I mean that's there's there is
no question and from our perspective but
I like the fact that his story does have
an important YouTube element and and you
know we don't think there's anything to
be ashamed about I do understand that in
in the musical world there might be
people who are like oh yeah the guy who
had that YouTube video that would get
under your skin after a while but he's
more than overcome that still overcoming
sudden you know lots of things like the
the incident that he's apologizing for
on his latest album and the Epilepsy
that he's struggling with now and how
he's bringing those into his lyrics you
know I'm excited about this album
hopefully we'll get to see him when he
performs in town yeah we're appreciative
to George let him know what you think
show your appreciation by tweeting at
him gee watski follow him on Twitter
check out his tour dates on his website
George Watsky dot-com see him in person
we do appreciate the time that he spent
with us hashtag your biscuits let us
know what you think as well you can
count on us to be back here next week
with another one we'll be talking at the
same pace that we talked this week may
be slowly getting a little bit faster
thanks to the influence of George
[Music]
[Music]